Шановні колеги дуже добре що дійшли
нарешті до цього руки Я не знаю коли
кому заважала прозорість і підзвітність
тому що завдяки прозоро ми дізналися
наприклад про серіали на 400 млн грн
один з яких про паровоза паровознюка ми
дізналися від журналістів про яйця по 17
гривень мінобороні
І от зараз ми мали би показати те ж
приклад що прозорість - це стосується і
Верховної Ради України Кабінету
Міністрів України і тих новопризначених
людей вициа тих новопризначених людей в
регіонах які зараз не подавали жодних
декларацій не проводили жодних провірок
що до них не проводилося я взагалі
дивуюся що цю ініціативу зараз подають
Мої колеги тому що насправді цю
ініціативу давним-давно мав би подати
уряд України уряд Дениса шмигаля тому що
це одна із умов Європейського Союзу мені
і ми хочемо дуже почати переговори Ми
хочемо отримати цю нашу історичну
перемогу стати членами Європейського
Союзу мені не все подобається в проекті
який зараз поданий Мені не подобається
що там хочуть приховати оці Шалені
премії які будуть перевищувати насправді
нормальні норми В умовах воєнного стану
Я хочу знати хто отримує гроші більше
ніж їх отримують українські військові в
цих умовах Ну нащо ми це ховаємо зараз
коли суспільство хочеться знати я так
само мені не подобається наприклад що ми
збираємося ховати будь-яку оренду до 137
тисяч гривень чому з якого перепуга оце
от скажіть чого ми боїмося там багато
речей насправді чого ми ховаємо третіх
осіб якихось цих деклараціях чому ми так
всі переживаємо насправді небезпека
сьогодні є тим хто на лінії фронту ти
люди які на лінії фронту хочуть від нас
під звітності і прозорості Давайте
будемо їх поважати давайте зараз
голосувати за те що було впроваджено в
16-му році і нормально працювали і
давайте мати повагу сьогодні до
українського війська яке єдине сьогодні
перебуває в